Do you want your sweaters to fit better?
Ad bust darts.
Are you larger than an "A" cup?
Add bust darts.
Do you tend to yank down on the fronts
of your sweaters when you wear them?
Add bust darts.
Consider adding them to your next sweater
even if your pattern doesn't include them,
you'll be pleasantly
surprised at the improved fit.
Here are some things to consider.
Our goal is to add some length to the
center front of your sweater so that the
hem hangs parallel to the floor.
Use your measurements to determine if you
need one inch or three inches or more.
Where to add them is the
next thing to consider.
Where should the dart start?
You want the dart to point
to the apex of your bust.
So measure down from your shoulder where
your shoulder seam would be to determine
where to start your shaping.
Generally you'll knit the dart
before the armhole shaping.
The Knit it Now patterns position the
darts one inch before the armhole shaping.
But measure to see where
this would be best for you.
How deep should the dart be?
The rule of thumb is that bust darts
should end approximately two inches from
the apex of your bust.
This gives a nice soft,
flattering curve to the fabric.
Measure from your side seam to this point.
Before we get involved with any math,
let's talk a little about the actual
knitting of darts.
On the knitting machine
this is pretty straight forward.
We will work short row shaping
or also called partial knitting.
We're going to add more rows to the center
front of the garment piece without adding
any length to the side seams.
Now, if you aren't familiar with short
rows or holding and wrapping, please look
for the tutorials in our learning library.
Basically, you set your
carriage to the hold setting.
And you pull groups of
needles to hold position.
In this example, I've changed to a
contrast in color as I started forming my
dirt shaping to make a little more clear.
I'm adding a single dart on one side of
the work as if I were knitting a cardigan
front.
Following my pattern, I'm putting a group
of needles that are opposite the carriage
into hold position.
I'll knit across and manually wrap that
first needle to prevent a hole and knit
back.
I'll keep repeating this according again,
according to my pattern and notice how the
white section is getting longer.
This is going to be the
center front of my sweater.
In this example, I've worked stripes so
you can see the shaping a little more
clearly.
Notice that between the markers is the
additional length that I've added that
will accomplish our goal of adding
inches to the center front of my garment.
Look closely at a solid
color and plain knitting.
The wrapped stitches.
The short rows really
aren't that noticeable.
I've determined that I want
my dart to start at this row.
I need two inches of additional length and
I want my dart to be four inches in from
the side seam.
Now I could get out my calculator and use
the magic formula and do bunch of math,
but why not just use the
Knit it Now dart tool?
Let us do the math for you.
Fill in the blanks.
Click.And voila.
Here are your shaping instructions.
This tool is free for Knit it Now,
subscribers, and it's included in our
dynamic patterns that offer
optional bust dart shaping.
Adding bust darts will improve
the fit of your sweaters.
Give them a try.
I'm sure you will be
pleased with the results.
Thanks for watching.